[Musique]
après l'adoption du projet de loi sur
l'extension du pass sanitaire par le
parlement autour du conseil
constitutionnel de trancher ce sera le 5
août dans le même temps face à la menace
d'une quatrième vague la vaccination se
poursuit 40 millions de personnes ont
désormais reçu une première dose mais
vous le verrez dans certains
départements comme dans les côtes
d'armor les vaccins viennent à manquer
[Musique]
en pleine crise sanitaire la tunisie
s'enfonce dans un marasme politique
après une journée de manifestation hier
dans plusieurs villes du pays kai eide a
limogé le premier ministre vient de
faire de même avec le ministre de la
défense le président a aussi jolie les
activités du parlement il s'est octroyé
le pouvoir exécutif une décision
qualifiée de coup d'état par ennahda le
principal parti à parlementaire ce matin
des heurts ont éclaté devant le
parlement
[Musique]
au liban najib mikati est chargé de
former un nouveau gouvernement il s'agit
du troisième premier ministre désigné en
un an par le président michel aoun
il a également reçu le soutien du
précédent premier ministre désigné saad
hariri
la gym mikati qui n'est pas une figure
connue de la scène politique libanaise
il a déjà occupé le poste de premier
ministre à deux reprises
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france il est 20 heures
quatre jours et quatre nuits de débats à
l'assemblée puis au sénat et au final un
compromis trouvé hier soir sur le projet
de loi sanitaire voulue par le
gouvernement début août le passé ni
terre sera bien en étant dû au café au
restaurant ou encore aux avions et aux
trains le texte doit maintenant passer
devant le conseil constitutionnel avant
d'être promulgué les sages rendront leur
décision la semaine prochaine les médias
ce qu'a fait david aux épices une
dernière décision le 5 août
le conseil constitutionnel a annoncé
avoir été saisis ce lundi et s'engage à
faire connaître son avis à cette date
comme prévu le pass sanitaire sera exigé
pour accéder à de nouveaux lieux dès que
la loi entrera en vigueur
ce sera notamment le cas dans les
transports publics inter-régionaux le
pass s'appliquera aussi aux lieux qui
accueillent des activités de loisirs les
foires et salons professionnels seront
également concernés le sésame sera
obligatoire dans les restaurants cafés
et bars y compris en terrasse seule
exception la vente à emporter
l'accès aux hôpitaux aux ehpad ainsi qu
aux autres lieux de soins et
établissements médico-sociaux
nécessitera aussi la présentation du
pass sanitaire en revanche l'extension
du contrôle du pass aux centres
commerciaux qui a été débattu jusqu'à la
dernière minute n'a pas été généralisée
à défaut de s'appliquer de manière
systématique
la mesure pourra être décidé par les
préfets la majorité se félicite de
l'adoption de ces mesures
une victoire contre le virus et sous les
opposants au pass sanitaires belle
soirée pour la démocratie mauvaise pour
le virus le parlement adopte le pass and
i ter la vaccination obligatoire des
soignants le renforcement de l'isolément
après 60 heures de débats majorité et
opposition ont su retrouver le chemin de
l'unité pour lutter contre l'épidémie
après 55 heures de débat au parlement le
projet de loi est définitivement adopté
ces mesures sont indispensables compte
tenu de la situation sanitaire
laliberté n'exclura jamais la
responsabilité
l'une un pic l'autre continuons de tenir
ensemble mais les modalités de cette
adoption laisse un goût amer dans
l'opposition une manoeuvre nocturne à
l'assemblée ou alors plusieurs votes
contre au sénat dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche sans compter les manifestations
anti passe sanitaires à travers le pays
ce week-end
rassemblant des dizaines de milliers de
personnes dans les rues
un texte loin de faire l'unanimité chez
une majorité de français d'autant plus
que l'opposition dénonce toujours une
loi passée en force qui pourrait
restreindre certaines libertés pour les
amis de la liberté
mieux vaut se tromper en oubliant
d'interdire qu'en interdisant trop non
nous ne sommes pas un peuple de patients
ni de délinquants potentiels mais un
peuple de citoyens députés sénateurs
auraient trouvé un accord ce soir pour
adopter la loi de la honte
celle qui fait basculer la france dans
l'apartheid avec le pass de la hante les
républicains pouvait freiner les choses
au sénat mais on préférait la
compromission
le peuple de france wagon des libertés
il arrive à être aussi incohérent que
fout pas de passes annie terre dans le
rer mais obligatoire dans le tgv et
allons plus loin en novembre le ministre
djebbari nous disait lui même que les
transports publics n'étaient pas des
lieux de contamination
il faudrait savoir au delà du 15
novembre le dispositif du pass sanitaire
ne pourra être maintenu sans un nouveau
vote du parlement
en attendant la vaccination continue de
progresser dans l'hexagone d'après
emmanuel macron via twitter la barre des
40 millions de français primo vacciner a
été franchi ce lundi un texte adopté
dans la précipitation selon ses
détracteurs c'est l'édito de nicolas
vidal selon lui les sénateurs n'ont rien
obtenu la fibre liberticide est toujours
là je suis surpris par contre par la
fanfaronnade de des sénateurs finalement
qui nous en dit qu'is avaient eu un
compromis rappelez-vous hier après midi
il ya eu des suspensions de séance de la
commission paritaire bien entendu mais
finalement qu'est ce qu'ils ont gagné
les sénateurs qu'est ce qu'on gagne et
sénateurs absolument rien les sénateurs
hier je le dis 1 se sont couchés
notamment sur l'exclusion du pass à
lithaire en terrasses notamment bars
restaurants mais aussi pour les mineurs
aujourd'hui moi j'ai une nouvelle fois
le goût comme il ya quelques jours d'une
mascarade démocratique dans ce pays est
une nouvelle fois quand j'entends les
sénateurs notamment républicain c'est
réjouir de ce qu'ils ont obtenu
mais en fait ils n'ont rien obtenu pour
quoi ils n'ont rien obtenu parce que
finalement la fibre liberticide et
toujours dans ce texte dans ce pas
salutaire et on l'a vu avec beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de manifestants à ces
derniers jours pour pour revendiquer
finalement l'exclusion du passage du ter
dans ce pays nouvelle flambée des
contaminations aux variants delta en 24
heures plus de 16 mille nouveaux cas ont
été recensés pour le moment la pression
sur les services de réanimation reste
contenue mais les autorités craignent
que celle-ci augmenté notamment à court
terme 8 178 malades sont actuellement en
réanimation mais les premiers signaux
d'une quatrième vague se font déjà
ressentir
estelle farges un risque majeur pour les
hôpitaux c'est ce que représente la
quatrième vague de covile 19 si elle
arrive en août déclarations du directeur
de la rs de la région ile de france dans
les colonnes du jdd
le risque majeur ce serait une arrivée
précoce de la vague en août
en période de pénurie d'effectifs si
elle a lieu en septembre les personnels
seront plus nombreux à voir repris mais
on n'évacue pas un an et demi de
mobilisation en quelques semaines de
congés problème selon lui les
modélisations de l'épidémie sont plus
incertaines que l'été dernier quart face
aux variants delta on ignore encore
quels freins jours à la vaccination qui
reste tout de même selon lui une arme
massive face au virus sur la semaine du
12 au 18 juillet le taux
d'hospitalisations a augmenté de 55%
avec 1215 nouvelles hospitalisations et
les admissions en soins critiques de 35%
par rapport à la semaine précédente
selon le bulletin épidémiologique de
santé publique france daté du 20
2 juillet si la situation dans les
établissements hospitaliers reste encore
tenable les chiffres des contaminations
provoque tout de même quelques
inquiétudes
au vu de la contagiosité du variant
delta les couvertures vaccinales des
populations âgées et fragiles sont
encore clairement insuffisante pour
qu'on puisse être assuré que l'impact
sur le système de santé ne va pas être
dans les semaines à venir conséquent du
côté de la vaccination le pays aurait
franchi d'après emmanuel macron la barre
symbolique des 40 millions de primo
vacciner plus de 33 millions de
personnes présentes un schéma vaccinal
complet soit un peu plus de 49% de la
population de l'hexagone tenter
d'endiguer la quatrième vague avec pour
arme la vaccination 40 millions de
personnes ont reçu une première dose la
demande est forte mais l'offre n'est pas
toujours au rendez vous et les doses de
vaccin manque parfois en particulier
dans les zones rurales
reportage dans les côtes d'armor de
cyrielle beau et gentil démoli depuis
les annonces des manuels macron il ya
deux semaines de plus en plus de
français demande à se faire vacciner
contre le coc vie 19 mai dans cet
établissement regroupant plusieurs
professionnels de santé à saint-alban
dans les côtes d'armor les doses de
vaccin manquent à l'appel face au report
de sa première injection ou ce patient
oscille entre incompréhension et
interrogations j'arrive j'avais rendez
vous à 15h 15 rendez vous qui était
programmé depuis une quinzaine de jours
et bah là j'apprends arrivés sur place
que il ya plus de doses je n'ai plus de
doses pour me faire vacciner quoi et
c'est un petit peu contradictoire on
nous demande de faire un donc l'effort
de la de se faire vacciner le plus vite
possible et on s'aperçoit que ben yahia
pas les doses nécessaires pour vacciner
ceux qui veulent le faire quoi si la
vaccination est possible dans les
cabinets d'infirmiers libéraux les
quantités de serre sommes mises à leur
disposition sont parfois insuffisantes
une situation dénoncée par les patients
de cette maison de santé au river cette
étape 2
de cette pandémie en fait on devrait pas
avoir le droit de manquer dos quoi on
nous fait la promo mais la pression pour
se faire vacciner
et d'un autre côté il n'y a pas ces deux
là la base je voulais inscrire tout le
monde
voilà un point de rendez vous pour tout
le monde et on n'a pas vu parce que ben
justement ils n'ont pas les doses et
même sur les sites internet
ya pas de place à part rennes qui est à
une heure de route face à la hausse
spectaculaire des prises de rendez vous
depuis les annonces du chef de l'état
notamment sur le pass annie taire
certains infirmiers libéraux ne
parviennent pas à se faire livrer
suffisamment de doses de vaccins thénot
deux flacons de godard doc on a réussi à
voir très difficilement ce flacon là il
est un médecin
ce flacon là il est un pharmacien mais
nous nous n'avons pas reçu nos doses de
vaccin pour que nous avons commandé il
ya maintenant treize jours fabien soro a
décidé de lancer un appel aux autorités
depuis le début de la crise ça a été ça
en fait il ya les annonces et après ce
qui se passe sur le terrain nous on veut
des doses
on nous dit qu'il y à des doses mais sur
le terrain en fait on a de grosses
difficultés à s'approvisionner
les professionnels de santé ne sont pas
les seuls à vouloir augmenter la cadence
pierre-alexis blévin maire de pléneuf
val andré a souhaité mettre en place un
centre de vaccination éphémère dans deux
de ces espaces municipaux dont un au
casino pour cela les deals dont la
population passe de 4500 habitants à
plus de 30000 durant l'été adressé un
courrier au préfet des côtes d'armor
une lettre qui n'a toujours pas reçu de
réponse d'un côté on nous dit il faut
vacciner plus et d'un autre côté quand
on dit on veut vous donner les moyens
pour pouvoir vous permettre de vacciner
plus pas cons et qu'on ait pas de
réponse les services de l'état sont
conscients que on a des risques de
d'épidémie d'augmentation de l'épidémie
et pour autant on nous répond pas et on
nous aide pas à
à renforcer en tous les cas le la
vaccination sur les sur les territoires
touristiques qui aujourd'hui sont ont
explosé avec avec la saison estivale
de son côté loïc chesnais girard
président de la région bretagne a émis
le souhait que les bretons soient les
premiers en france à atteindre
l'immunité collective d'ici à la fin
août
la france devrait recevoir 23 million de
nouvelles doses de vaccins de précieux
sérum que l'on risque de s'arracher en
particulier dans les zones rurales ou
enclavées qui risquent d'être les
derniers servis situation sanitaire
ailleurs dans le monde on parlera au
vietnam où l'augmentation des cas de
coronavirus implique de nouvelles
restrictions pour les habitants outre
des mesures de quarantaine des
opérations de désinfection sont mises en
place pour tenter d'endiguer la
propagation du virus
grégoire douce et
[Musique]
une désinfection à grande échelle dans
la capitale vietnamienne hanoï les
grands moyens sont déployés pour faire
face à une résurgence des cas de covin
19 le variant delta poussent les
autorités à mobiliser des groupes de
militaires pour diffuser du désinfectant
dans certaines zones de la ville 180
militaires et 15 véhicules se joignent à
cet effort de lutte contre la pandémie
nous avons tiré les leçons de nos
expériences passées lors des précédents
des infections désinfecter la cité
d'hanoï dans sa totalité semble peine
perdue elle les effectifs se concentre
donc sur des parties spécifiques
là où le virus circule le plus nous
avons identifié est concentrée la
désinfection sur les zones mises en
quarantaine est confiné ainsi que sur
les zones à haut risque où les gens sont
fortement exposés au virus alors que les
indicateurs épidémique s'affolent et que
la campagne vaccinale peine à décoller
les millions de personnes qui peuplent
la ville sont soumises depuis samedi
dernier à des mesures de confinement
le bras de fer dure et depuis des mois
en tunisie à l'issue d'une nouvelle
journée de mobilisation partout dans le
pays
hier le président qu'elle cède à geler
les travaux du parlement limogeant dans
la foulée le premier ministre seront par
ennahdha principal parti au pouvoir qui
dénonce un coup d'état qu'est sayyed a
fait de même avec le ministre de la
défense ce matin des affrontements ont
éclaté entre partisans devant le
parlement tunisien le point avec notre
correspondant bassel chez bis
au lendemain de cette annonce surprise
du président de la république tunisienne
et kaïs sayed de limoger le premier
ministre et de geler le parlement s'en
est suivi une journée assez mouvementée
dans l'ensemble du pays et
principalement à tunis la capitale aux
abords du parlement un parlement qui a
été protégée est quadrillée par des
militaires instruction du président de
la république interdire tout accès aux
bâtiments aux parlementaires les
parlementaires du parti islamiste
ennahda parti contestataire de cette
décision du président de la république
qu'il juge anticonstitutionnelle ont
tenté de pénétrer dans le bâtiment
un accès qui leur a été interdit par les
forces de l'ordre mais surtout par
l'armée aux abords de ce parlement il ya
eu des confrontations entre pro et nada
et anti ennahda des jets de pierres des
tensions la police a essayé de calmer la
foule et de les disperser mais sans
violence des slogans hostiles au parti
ennahda et surtout à monsieur ghannouchi
alors que la tunisie vit actuellement
une sorte de transition le président de
la république a reçu aujourd'hui le
principal de la principale la tête de
liste du de luge et était le syndicat le
plus puissant de tunisie des discussions
sont encore en cours le président de la
république a également annoncé d'autres
limogeages à savoir celui du ministre de
la défense l'aéroport de tunis carthage
a été arrêté fermé toutes les frontières
aériennes et maritimes sont pour le
moment en stand by
et puis on attend encore de savoir
quelles seront les décisions et les
recommandations prises par le président
de la république est tunisien retiennent
leur souffle après une soirée de liesse
et attendent beaucoup du président de la
république on a pu en rencontrer
beaucoup aux abords de ce parlement qui
nous ont dit que c'était un jour
historique pour eux et qu'ils voulaient
absolument se débarrasser ce parlement
et surtout du parti ennahdha qu'ils
accusent d'être à la tête des maux de la
société et surtout tu malaise économique
politique et sociale qui vivent
actuellement les tunisiens partisans du
président qui essayait des manifestants
pour ennahdha se sont exprimé au micro
de rtl france écoutez
ce jour symbolise la division entre le
vrai le faux entre la légalité et
l'illégalité nous aujourd'hui moi en
tant que personne je me soulève pour
soutenir tous ceux qui se soulèvent pour
la vérité je soutiens la légalité la loi
la constitution le parlement élu par le
peuple
ce parlement qui doit être respecté nous
au sein du mouvement ennahdha nous
attendons l'avis de l'ensemble des
magistrats des syndicats de magistrats
ainsi que l'avis des doyens des
magistrats du pays les enfants de ce
pays ne sont pas leurs simples
locataires
ce qui nous sauve ni d'une aide du monde
pour nous dire les choses s'arranger
dans ce pays alors qu'ils nous ont fait
revenir en arrière
ça suffit partait rentrer chez nous
lâche et nous nous allons vivre dans
notre pays
comme nous le voulons ça suffit hier le
président lorsqu'il s'est exprimé il
nous a rendu notre pays il nous a rendu
la tunisie il ne me l'a pas rendu à moi
il l'a rendue à mes enfants
il a rendu à cette jeunesse qu'on a
laissé tomber c'est la vérité c'est ça
qu'il nous a donnée il nous a fait le
plus beau des cadeaux pour la fête de la
république
il nous a rendu la tunisie la république
tunisienne hier ce fut un événement une
réussite historique c'est à dire que
pour nous en tunisie nous comparons cela
la révolution la révolution de 2021
s'est produite le jour de la fête de la
république parce que pour nous cette
situation n'était plus supportable
depuis dix ans ennahda nous à gouverner
rien ne s'est passé
le pays continue à sombrer a chuté c'est
à dire que c'est quelque chose qui ne
convient pas du tout et nous nous sommes
venus pour chasser nada ennahda dégage
alors peut-on parler de coup d'état
comme le dénonce le parti ennahdha
décryptage des thèmes nafti essayiste
auteur de l'ouvragé de la révolution à
la restauration où va la tunisie aux
éditions riveneuve le problème c'est que
pour dire le droit il y à une cour
constitutionnelle qui aurait dû être
mise en place selon cette même
constitution depuis au moins l'année
2015 donc depuis maintenant six ans donc
tout le monde a plus ou moins violé la
constitution c'est à dire que
l'interprétation du président de la
république de cet article 80 il y a
clairement un dépassement notamment dans
le jeu fait le gel des activités du
parlement
mais en même temps en face aussi on a
une coalition au pouvoir et notamment au
parti islamiste qui ne s'est pas gêné
pour aussi en tout cas s'arranger avec
certaines dispositions aussi bien
légistatives que constitutionnel donc un
coup d'état il est trop tôt pour le dire
mais en tout cas l'article 86 devait
être appliquée dans le texte n'aurait
pas permis en tout cas le le gel des
activités du parlement au liban najib
mikati officiellement chargé de former
un nouveau gouvernement il était donné
grand favori il devient le troisième
premier ministre en un an
désigné par le président libanais michel
aoun à l'issue de consultations avec les
différents blocs parlementaires
il a reçu l'appui de 72 d'entre eux 42
des [ __ ] députés se sont abstenus
l'ancien chef du gouvernement et hommes
d'affaires prend donc la relève après la
démission de saad hariri il y a dix
jours il a la lourde tâche de former une
nouvelle équipe ministérielle avec un
objectif lancer les réformes
indispensables au pays afin de
bénéficier à nouveau de l'aide
internationale
nous devons tous être solidaires je sais
que c'est une étape difficile mais je
vous dis que je suis confiant j'ai
étudié la question de la formation d'un
nouveau gouvernement pendant un certain
temps
si je n'avais pas les garanties
extérieurs nécessaires et si je ne
savais pas qu'il était temps que
quelqu'un prenne cette question en main
face à la détérioration de la situation
je n'aurais pas accepté ce poste michael
est pour françois lb chat économiste et
fondateur de l'iba news la nomination de
nez
nicati ne devrait pas changer grand
chose à la politique libanaise est
l'homme du compromis
donc c'est en cela qu'il a le profil un
peu pour sortir de la crise politique
mais la deuxième question qui se pose
c'est est ce qu'il arrivera justement à
dépasser même ses intérêts personnels
pour sortir de la crise économique et ça
on peut en douter
najib mikati n'est pas seulement
controversé au liban à cause des
détournements de fonds etc
mais il a aussi fait l'objet d'une
enquête le député européen concernant
des détournements de fonds européens au
liban et dernièrement il leur achetait
une entreprise de télécommunications en
birmanie et on le dit rabih à la jambe
birmane aussi donc c'est un homme qui va
jusqu'au bout de ces compromis parce que
l'argent pour lui n'a pas d'odeur
et sur ce point par exemple il n'est
quand même actionnaire de banque au
liban et on va voir quelle sorte de
compromis ils doivent faire avec le
système bancaire au détriment des
déposants probablement où on espère du
côté de la présidence de république
pouvoir être optimiste mais si on voit
un peu plus les choses d'un autre angle
on voit plutôt le prolongement de la
mission de saad hariri vient najib
mikati
les états unis poursuivront leurs
frappes en afghanistan si les talibans
continuent leur offensive une mise en
garde lancée hier par le chef des
opérations militaires américaines en
soutien au gouvernement afghan dépassé
par l'avancée des insurgés c'est pour la
contenir qu'il a décrété un couvre-feu
sur l'ensemble du territoire seules
trois provinces dont celle de kaboul ne
sont pas concernés par la mesure
alors que leur retrait est pratiquement
achevée les troupes américaines
continueront donc à soutenir les forces
afghanes jusqu'à l'arrêt des combats
les etats-unis ont augmenté leurs
frappes aériennes pour soutenir les
forces afghanes
au cours des derniers jours et nous
sommes prêts à maintenir ce niveau de
soutien accru dans les semaines à venir
si les talibans poursuivent leurs
attaques
je tiens à être très clair le
gouvernement afghan est confrontée à un
test sévère dans les jours à venir
les talibans tentent de créer un
sentiment d' inévitables it et dans leur
campagne ils ont tort il n'y a pas de
conclusion prix établi à ce combat la
victoire des talibans n'est pas
inévitable
le premier ministre irakien mustapha el
casimir reçu à la maison blanche ce
lundi une première rencontre avec joe
biden au coeur des discussions la
présence militaire américaine en irak
2500 soldats sont encore déployés dans
le pays mais aucune troupes combattantes
face aux difficultés des autorités
irakiennes pour contenir les agissements
des cellules de l'organisation a
terrorist état islamique
mustapha el kacimi souhaiterait que
washington réévalue sa présence
militaire
un sujet abordé lors d'une rencontre
préliminaire entre anthony blinken et
son homologue
il y a quelques jours nous sommes les
partenaires les plus proches dans la
lutte contre l'organisation état
islamique et nous pouvons être
extrêmement fier du travail que nous
avons accompli ensemble pour la vaincre
et nous assurer qu'elles restent vaincu
mais je pense que ce que l'on voit
aujourd'hui c'est que le partenariat
entre les etats-unis et l'irak est
beaucoup plus large et plus profond que
la lutte commune contre l'organisation
était islamique
nous avons besoin de la coopération avec
la coalition internationale de
travailler avec la coalition
internationale sous la direction des
etats-unis contre l'organisation état
islamique
il faut un échange d'informations avec
la coalition internationale les états
unis et l'irak pour vaincre le premier
ministre russe michail michou steen
étant en déplacement sur l'île dit où il
ruse de l'archipel des kouriles
revendiquées par le japon
une visite qui provoque la colère la
correspondance à moscou food antoine
cléroux le premier ministre russe en
déplacement dans l'extrême orient du
pays a pour objectif de trouver des axes
de développement économique pour ces
territoires très éloignés de moscou et
ce déplacement dans les îles kouriles
n'a pas été très bien accueillie du côté
des autorités japonaises et pour cause
cet archipel se trouve au coeur d'un
différend territorial entre le japon et
la russie
et ce depuis la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale la venue de michael mais justin
sur ce territoire disputé a donc
provoqué ce matin la convocation de
l'ambassadeur russe en poste à tokyo une
convocation au ministère japonais des
affaires étrangères et dans la foulée
toujours ce matin l'ambassadeur en poste
l'ambassadeur japonais en poste à moscou
a à son tour été convoqué au ministère
russe des affaires étrangères malgré
tout le kremlin se veut rassurant et
espère que ce différend ce litige
territorial trouvera bientôt une issue
heureuse
eh bien vous savez qu'un accord de paix
peut mettre un terme à cette histoire
vous savez qu'au fil des ans de grands
efforts ont été déployés
y compris par le président poutine
pourtant venir à cet accord de paix sur
cette voie il y a des difficultés qui
sont bien connues les malgré elle ou il
existe du moins de la part de la russie
une forte volonté politique de
développer de bonnes relations avec
notre voisin oriental qu'elle au japon
il est vrai que depuis des années
maintenant les deux pays tentent de
tourner la page de ce différend
territorial le nouveau premier ministre
japonais yoshi des souks a déclaré
d'ailleurs en début d'année vouloir ne
pas transmettre cette dispute aux
générations futures car rappelons le à
l'heure actuelle la russie et le japon
n'ont toujours pas signé de traité de
paix à l'issue de la seconde guerre
mondiale et sont donc techniquement
encore en guerre c'est la fin de cette
édition merci à vous de l'avoir suivi
prochain journal dans une trentaine de
minutes est tout à l'heure
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous répondez quand on
vous soupçonne et on soupçonne votre
industrie d'être sulfureuse
d'industriels extrêmement contrôlée
pourquoi puisque reverse 50 5 % de notre
chiffre d'affaires à l'état et à la
commune qui sont donc très intéressé au
fait que le
fonctionnement soit line ont fait
exactement comme les banques les
compagnies d'assurances cnia d'argent
suspects nous sommes dans l'obligation
de le déclarer comment se répartit 100
euros de mise globalement aux machines à
sou par exemple moi j'ai dans
l'obligation de vendre en moyenne 85%
que nous on n'a absolument aucun intérêt
à ce que quelqu'un aille raconter qu'il
est ruiné au casino pas certains
pouvaient dépenser des sommes
extrêmement importantes allant jusqu'aux
millions d'euros aujourd'hui ça n'existe
plus on est beaucoup plus dans le loisir
aujourd'hui ce qui fait notre marge
c'est la fréquentation et le nombre
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la peuplent
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sent du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend
sable est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
sous les numéros l'uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes comment ces mecs-là
arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi je
pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
d'inusité gilet jaune c'était des
valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent ces
gens qui avaient envie de transmettre
quelque chose à leurs enfants
[Musique]
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie d'avoir un huitième
[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous nous allons
évoquer ici des sujets stratégiques et
sur ces dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous mon
interprétation tous les jours dans les
médias
nous entendons des accusations de
complotisme contre ceux qui n'adhèrent
pas à la pensée convenue en contrepoint
ceux qui les accusent même des actions
d' influence pour obliger la majorité
des citoyens à adhérer à leur point de
vue ainsi dans le débat d'idées c'est
créer une barrière infranchissable
opposant les défenseurs du bien commun
et les thuriféraires du mal à peser les
conséquences en sont graves puisque en
contradiction avec les principes mêmes
de la démocratie
il s'agit d'interdire la liberté de
penser autrement sous peine d'exclusion
l'amendement numéro 1 de la constitution
des états unis stipule que le congrès
n'adoptera aucune loi relative à
l'établissement d'une religion ou à
l'interdiction de son libre exercice ou
pour limiter l'expression de la presse
ou le droit des citoyens de se réunir
pacifiquement et d'adresser au
gouvernement des pétitions pour obtenir
réparation des torts subis
l'article 19 de la constitution
française affirme que tout individu a
droit à la liberté d'opinion et
d'expression ce qui implique le droit de
ne pas être inquiété pour ses opinions
et celui de chercher de recevoir et de
répandre les informations les idées sans
considération de frontières par quelque
moyen d'expression que ce soit
on en est loin quand on voit aux états
unis et en france
certains médias et administrations sous
la pression de groupes minoritaires
puissant rejeter ou interdire de parole
des associations des partis ou des
porteurs d'idées dont le tort est de
refuser la tyrannie de la bien pensante
pourtant c'est du débat qu'on s'enrichit
de nos différences et connaît la
solution constructive qui peut être
partagé en vérité l'accusation de
complotisme est de plus en plus employée
par des gens qui ignorent ce que le mot
veut dire la définition du larousse
précise qu'on emploie ce mot pour
désigner quelqu'un ou un groupe qui
réfutent la version communément admise
d'un événement et cherche à démontrer
que celui ci résulte d'un complot mené
par une minorité active dans l'histoire
le complotisme repose généralement sur
une interprétation qui peut aller dans
ses excès jusqu'à la négation de la
réalité historique dans un sens ou dans
un autre
alimenté par des fake news fausse
partiellement fausses ou des infos
vraies qui aurait dû rester secrète
il peut délibérément devenir actions d'
influence quand il est exercé par le
camp de la bien-pensance
dans le fond la théorie du complot
l'explication la plus simple et la plus
facile d'autant qu'elle permet de
désigner un bouc émissaire
évidemment coupable du pire on en a
aujourd'hui un exemple un terrain